-We're down to the second...
-Dude,
game's on in five minutes.
Got any snacks?
-Wings? Chips? Beer?
-This party's in trouble.
[ Doorbell rings ]
♪♪
-Not anymore.
[ Cassette player clicks ]
-♪ We are
the Football Party Patrol ♪
♪ Getting your party
out of control ♪
♪ So when you need snacks
for the big game ♪
♪ Call the Party Patrol,
we'll save the day ♪
♪ Got the wings marinating
in the fridge ♪
-♪ With the sauce so hot,
it'll burn your lips ♪
[ Wilhelm scream ]
-♪ If you need a drink,
well, we got 'em all ♪
-♪ Cheese curls, cheese puffs,
and of course ♪
-♪ Cheese balls ♪
-♪ Got a jersey on
of your favorite player ♪
-♪ Got that dip
made of seven layers ♪
-♪ All our friends
coming to this house ♪
♪ Just use a napkin,
don't wipe on the couch ♪
-♪ And I brought
15 pounds of cod ♪
♪ I caught it in the sea
with my fishing rod ♪
♪ Cod is the perfect
football snack ♪
♪ Loaded with omega-3s,
that's the good fat ♪
[ Music stops ]
Sounds good, right? Guys?
-♪ Cool, but what about
the chips and guac? ♪
♪ All I want to do
is eat that guac ♪
♪ I wish I could
get paid in guac ♪
♪ Avocado, jalapeños,
how I like to rock ♪
-♪ Then bop a jalapeño popper ♪
♪ Queso so hot,
it's a bopper shocker ♪
♪ Can't get enough
of these football snacks ♪
-♪ But it stinks like fish,
and that's kinda wack ♪
-♪ That's on account
of the cod I brought ♪
♪ I put it in the microwave
to make it hot ♪
♪ The bad smell's
from the fishy steam ♪
♪ Crammed with phosphorous
and protein ♪
-♪ Maybe we could put the cod
in the freezer ♪
-♪ Or we could eat it,
that'd be easier ♪
-♪ How about we put all the cod
outside? ♪
-♪ Sure, then I'll bring
more cod inside ♪
-♪ Maybe we could put the cod
in the trash ♪
-No! No!
[ Record scratches ]
Nobody's going to be putting
the cod in the trash!
Everybody is going to eat
the cod because I brought it,
and that's the end of it.
That's the end of it!
If someone brings a dish
to a party, you try it.
You try it.
Just one bite, okay?
One bite.
That's it. That's the rule.
That's the Party Patrol
politeness rule.
Just one bite.
♪♪
[ Squishing ]
[ Munching ]
[ Munching continues ]
-♪ So, maybe we were
too hard on the cod ♪
-♪ Now you're on your way
to a killer bod ♪
-♪ A football snack
fresh from the sea ♪
-♪ Dense, white flesh,
yeah, that's for me ♪
-♪ We are
the Football Party Patrol ♪
♪ Getting your party
out of control ♪
♪ So if you need snacks
for your squad ♪
♪ Call the Party Patrol,
and we'll bring the cod ♪
-Cod goals!
[ Squish! ]